il faut traverser quatre mètres de béton
de 160 mille litres d'eau pressurisée
sans rien de mécanique sans bouteille
d'oxygène en bonifiant et donne des
bruits un point important si tu n'as pas
ouvrir le panneau au bout de deux
minutes et demi qu'on est mort tous les
deux n'ont fait que tu mets toi arrête
maintenant je suis rendu
mais attends attends attends attends tu
peux conduire ya une minute et est mort
vers jeannot quoi tu parles
tout ça va mal finir
monsieur le président l'heure est venue
de dissoudre mission impossible
ce n'est pas juste une organisation
dissidente
elle s'est déshonoré
dissoudre mission impossible est une
erreur que vous pourriez regretter
pendu côte ligure il appelle le syndicat
est bien réelle
ils savent qui nous sommes c'est une
nation dissidence entraînés à faire ce
que nous faisons une anti mission
impossible
ils feront tout pour nous avoir
ollo gauche vous voulez en finir avec le
syndicat c'est impossible
les propositions et un visuel de
spectacle va commencer d'abord vous et
votre équipe devrait répondre de chaque
acte de destruction dont il est
responsable
maintenant on est tous recherchés par la
cia
c'est l'heure
dominateurs c'est maintenant tu demandes
ça pourrait bien être notre dernière
édition
terminant en beauté
la porte à lévis mais pas j'essaye
bon c'est pas vrai